Welcome to our program. I'd like to know
this is a well-known program here at uh
Secrets and Seal Studios SMTV channel
and I am very happy to be part of it
today. Uh to my right I have here Pastor
Stephen Boore and we've been doing some
programs together already uh this this
time and thank you Pastor Boore for the
opportunity of of being here and
allowing me to be part of the program as
well.
>> We greatly appreciate your willingness
to help us in the midst of your very
busy schedule.
>> Thank you so much. and I am uh Daniel
Miranda, pastor here in the Central
California Conference and we're very
happy to be in this program. You know, I
really enjoyed this program.
>> Amen.
>> Uh we have the opportunity to interact
with people and some of these questions
are like, wow, it really helps you dig
deeper into scripture. There's questions
that [clears throat]
>> you personally don't don't think that
someone is going to ask. So, we really
appreciate your questions. If you if you
want to send more questions, there is an
email address where you could do so.
It's tvsumtv.org.
TV tvsv.org.
Please send your questions and most
likely they will be answered here in
this program. Uh before we begin, I
would like to kindly ask Pastor Bour to
please lead us in prayer.
Father in heaven, what a privilege it is
to open your word, to hear your voice
speaking to us. As long as we live in
this world, we will have many, many
questions.
>> Yes.
>> And some of them will not be answered
until we sit at the feet of Jesus in the
coming kingdom. How we long for that
day.
>> But meanwhile, we ask that in this
program, you will be with us through the
ministry of your Holy Spirit.
>> Amen.
>> Give us clarity of thought. Give us open
hearts. Give us open ears that we might
hear your voice and bless all of those
who are watching the program that their
lives might be greatly blessed by the
comfort of your word. We pray in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen. Our first question today is coming
from Dimmitri Kristoff from Dubai,
United Arab Emirates
and is to be honest this I really
enjoyed this question. I have never
thought of this before
>> and and maybe study this deeper. It says
in Matthew 27 verse 50 and 51, we read
Matthew 27:50 and 51, when Jesus had
cried out again with a loud voice, he
yielded up his spirit. At that moment,
the veil of the temple was torn in two
from top to bottom. This event signified
the close of the earthly sacrificial
system and pointed to the reality of
Christ's finished sacrifice on Calvary.
The rending of the veil showed that the
earthly temple services had met their
fulfillment in the true lamb of God.
However, I have often wondered if the
tearing of the earthly veil symbolized
the end of the earthly ministration and
the opening of direct access to God
through Christ.
Why did the second veil, the one
separating the holy place from the most
holy place in the heavenly century,
continue to exist until Christ
transition to the most holy in 1844? In
other words, how do we reconcile the
rending of the earthly veil at the cross
with the continued toface priestly
ministry of Christ in the heavenly
sanctuary until the commencement of the
antityypical day of atonement?
I [snorts] believe he answers his
question in the text because
in in the question I would say because
the reason for the rending of the veil
one of one of the symbols and and the
messages from that is that now we can
have direct access to God through Jesus.
What does the veil represent by the way?
Let's go to the book of Hebrews
chapter 6.
Um
and um
let's go here with verse 18- 20.
Hebrews chap 6 18-20. It says that by
two immutable things in which it is
impossible for God to lie, we might have
strong consolation, who have fled for
refuge to lay hold of the hope set
before us. This hope we have as an
anchor of the soul sure and and
steadfast which enters the presence
behind the veil where the forerunner has
entered for us even Jesus having become
a high priest forever according to the
order of MelkiseDC. So here it speaks of
the hope that we have as an anchor that
is within the veil and now we can have
access to that through Jesus Christ. Now
also in the book of Hebrews uh now
chapter 10 um we're going to read
chapter 10 just give me one moment here
um and verse 20. Uh it's it uses similar
language. I think these two verses are
in the same context. Hebrews chapter 10
and verse 20. And by a new and living
way which he consecrated for us through
the veil that is his flesh. You know
what happened with Jesus on the cross?
It's similar to what happened to the
veil. It was rent. You know and and and
and here it says that the veil is his
flesh. Now what is the message here? Uh
several things. Number one, the earthly
system, not only the most holy place
service, but the earthly system as a
whole came to an end. Number two,
through this we are taught that now we
have direct access to God through Jesus.
So because Jesus is the veil, but now is
rent, now through Jesus, we have direct
access to God. But that doesn't mean
that the services in the heavenly
century now there should not be the
service in the first apartment and the
second apartment because actually the
earthly century was a typology of the of
the reality which is the heavenly
century.
>> Sure. And Hebrews 8 makes that very very
clear.
Now this is the main point of the things
that we are saying. We have such a high
priest who is seated at the right hand
of the throne of the majesty in the
heavens, a minister of the sanctuary
and of the true tabernacle which the
Lord erected and not man.
>> Yes. And then verse five says, "Who
served the earthly things serve as a
copy and shadow of the heavenly things
as Moses was about to make the
tabernacle, for he said, see that you
make all things according to the pattern
shown you in the mountain."
So basically the rending of the veil to
the most holy place uh according to
desire of ages as well means the end of
the earthly system.
>> Correct? But it doesn't mean the end of
the heavenly system.
>> It's the earthly system that comes to an
end.
>> Exactly.
>> And um you know we know that because uh
where did Jesus go when he ascended to
heaven? Well during at the beginning of
the series of the churches he's walking
among the seven candlesticks.
>> They were in the holy place. When we
come to the beginning of the trumpets,
Jesus is at the altar of incense,
>> which was also in the holy place.
>> Yes.
>> And um I'm not going to go into all of
the evidence, but during the period of
the seals, he's at the table of
showbread.
>> So uh in the early part of Revelation,
he's in the holy place of the heavenly
sanctuary. Uh Ellen White also if you uh
accept the writings of Ellen White as
inspired which we do she uh was taken to
the sanctuary in vision in heaven and
she actually entered the holy place and
she says I saw the candlestick and I saw
the table of showbread. I saw the altar
of incense. Then the angel lifted the
veil and I entered into the most holy
place where I saw the ark and inside the
ark I saw the law the halo around the
fourth commandment. So, so she firmly
believed that in heaven there are two
apartments. Um, not only that, the book
of Revelation indicates so. Um, in
Revelation chapter 3, you have the
church of Philadelphia, which is the
church of the Millerite movement.
>> And God says, "I have placed before you
an open door."
>> And I've closed another door.
>> Now, which door was closed in 1844? It
was the door that led from the holy to
the most holy place,
right? The door that was closed. The
door that was open was the door to the
most holy place. And so, uh, Christ's
intercession in the holy place um takes
place until 1844. In after 1844, uh,
Jesus still intercedes in the most holy
place, but he adds a function which is
the function of the judgment. Mhm.
>> And furthermore, in Revelation 11:1 19,
uh it says uh the temple of God was open
in heaven and the ark of his testament
was seen
>> in uh the most holy place.
>> So very clearly the book of revelation
indicates that there are still two
apartments in heaven.
>> Absolutely. There is overwhelming
evidence that that the two apartment
ministry in heaven continues. Let me
read to you a [snorts] how Ellen White
comments on the rending of the veil here
in the book of Desire of Ages.
>> Um it says here in page 756
and 757.
It says here, "But the earth trembles
and quakes, for the Lord himself draws
near with the rending noise of the inner
veil of the temple is torn from top to
bottom by an unseen hand throwing open
to the gaze of the multitude a place
once filled with the presence of God."
You know, the most holy place was the
was the symbol of the presence of God,
the throne of God.
In this place, the Shikina had dwelt.
Here, God manifested his glory above the
mercy seat. No one but the high priest
ever lifted the veil separating this
apartment from the rest of the temple.
He entered once he enter in once a year
to make an atonement for the sins of the
people. But low this veil is rent in
twain. The most holy place of the
earthly century is no longer sacred.
>> So notice that she says of the earthly
century,
>> right?
>> This is not doing away with the heavenly
century.
>> All is terror or conf and confusion. The
priest is about to slay the victim, but
the knife drops from his nerveless hand
and the lamb escapes. Type has met
Anitype in the death of God's son. The
great sacrifice has been made. The way
into the holiest is laid open. A new and
living way is prepared for all. And we
just read this in the book of Hebrews.
No longer need sinful, sorrowing
humanity await the coming of the high
priest. Henceforth, the Savior was to
officiate as priest and advocate in the
heaven of heavens. It was as if a living
voice had spoken to the worshippers.
There is now an end to all the
sacrifices and offerings for sin. That's
the meaning of the rending of the veil.
The son of God is come according to his
word. Let me also read another text from
Daniel chapter 9.
Uh yeah, let's read verse
and
27.
This is describing the events of the
last week of the 70 weeks. After
[snorts] the 62 weeks, Messiah shall be
cut off, but not for himself.
And the people of the prince who is to
come shall destroy the city and the
sanctuary. The end of it shall be with a
flood until the end of the war.
Desolations are determined. Verse 27.
Then he shall confirm a covenant with
many for one week, but in the middle of
the week he shall bring an end to
sacrifice and offering. Here it is
prophecy to that. At the middle of the
week uh three years and a half later
after Messiah was anointed in the year
31 in the spring, Jesus died. He died on
the cross and he brought an end to
sacrifice and offering and this is
symbolized by the renting of the veil.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yeah.
>> So there's there's really no
contradiction in the fact that the uh
veil between the holy and the most holy
place was was rent when Jesus died. We
just need to remember that that
indicated that the earthly system of
holy, most holy, uh, court etc. had come
to an end
>> and that now the transition was being
made to the most holy place. Absolutely.
In heaven.
>> Yes. Thank you so much, Pastor Boore.
Well, our same brother uh has another
question. Uh, brother Dimitra
also related to the century. It says, "I
would deeply be grateful for your help
in understanding the following question.
Who served as the high priest in the
heavenly sanctuary before Jesus
inauguration as our high priest at his
ascension to heaven after his
resurrection?"
If if I may try to answer that question
and and perhaps you can
you can add some additional details,
Pastor Boore. Here again in in Daniel 9
there there is a prophecy that points to
this inauguration of this sanctuary.
It says in verse 24, Daniel 9:24,
"Seven weeks are determined
for your people and for your holy city
to finish the transgression, to make an
end of sins, to make reconciliation for
iniquity, to bring an eving
righteousness, to seal up vision and
prophecy, and to anoint the most holy or
the holy place or the sanctuary."
um to anoint the most holy. The
anointing of the most holy here is
pointing to the inauguration of the
sanctuary uh in the service of Jesus as
a high priest. This verse along with the
book of Hebrews where Jesus is
presented, we already read a text as a
high priest according to the order of
Melkisedc. I believe that even though
the century existed before, but now the
century acquires a new function because
the earthly centur century is no longer
uh functional. Now our direction is to
the heavenly century. So yes uh Jesus
has been that intercessor but now he
acquires a new function because now he
paid
uh with his life the sacrifice for our
sins and now that qualifies him to
become the high priest. This could not
happen before he had come a and died for
us because the high priest
uh if if if we go to another text in
Hebrews chapter 5,
we see that there are some
qualifications that the high priest had
to meet in order for him to be a high
priest. Um here in Hebrews chapter 5:es
1-4
it says for every high priest taken from
among men is appointed for men in things
pertaining to God that he may offer both
gifts and sacrifices for sin. He can
have compassion on those who are
ignorant and going astray since he
himself is also beset by wickedness.
Because of this he is recard as for the
people so also for himself to offer for
sins. And no man takes this honor to
himself, but he who is called by God
just as Aaron was called. And here is
the key. Verse five, so also Christ did
not glorify himself to become high
priest, but it was he who said to him,
you are my son today I have begotten
thee. And then verse six, he also says
in another place, you are a priest
forever according to the order of
Melkisedc. In other words, Jesus had to
offer sacrifices
first. He sacrificed his own life and he
who had he had to experience weakness as
we read here so that he can have
compassion of others to become a high
priest.
>> You know there's a text in in the book
of Romans chapter 3
and u uh 25 and 26 which helps us
understand this. The Old Testament
system was a system of IUS
if you please.
>> Uh in other words, uh the blood of bulls
and goats could not remove sin.
>> Yes.
>> Neither the priests were the they
symbolized the intercessor, but they
were not really intercessors in the
strict sense of the word. Uh and so in
the Old Testament system when an
individual uh brought a lamb, placed his
hand on the head of the lamb, confessed
his sin, and then slew the lamb and the
blood was taken into the into the holy
place. That symbolized the faith of the
person that Christ was going to come to
offer his life to definitively take care
of his sin. In other words, a sin was
forgiven
conditioned on Christ's coming and
paying uh for that sin. So, was there
salvation in the Old Testament? Yes. Uh
there was salvation by faith in the
Messiah to come.
>> These days, we have faith in the Messiah
that has come. Yes. In his blood. Now,
in this context, Romans chapter 3, and I
know you're an expert in Romans. wrote a
book on that uh on uh Romans
uh [clears throat] beginning maybe uh
let's uh begin here uh verse 21. But now
the righteousness of God apart from the
law is revealed being witnessed by the
law and the prophets. Even the
righteousness of God through faith in
Christ Jesus to all and on all who
believe for there is no difference. For
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory of God. being justified
uh freely by his grace through the
redemption that is in Christ Jesus.
>> Now verse 25 and 26 is key. Whom God set
forth as a propitiation by his blood
through faith to demonstrate his
righteousness because in his forbearance
God had passed over the sins that were
previously committed. In other words,
the sins were not legally forgiven in
the Old Testament except by faith in the
coming savior.
>> Yes.
>> And then verse 26, because of the death
of Christ, it says to demonstrate at the
present time his righteousness,
that is through Christ, that he might be
just and the justifier of the one who
has faith in Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> So in other words, in the Old Testament,
he passed over.
>> He accepted the faith in the coming
savior. Now he accepts faith in the
savior who has come.
>> Amen.
So just to summarize, Jesus has always
been the only true high priest in
heaven. But he was able to fulfill this
function after he came and became a
propitiation for our sins.
>> Yeah. If I could read a statement here
in early writings 126, it's powerful.
>> Technically speaking, Jesus has been
intercessor since man sinned. Yes,
>> since uh human beings sin uh actually he
was an intercessor in God's plan before
sin.
>> It was always planned that he would be
the intercessor. uh you know after Adam
and Eve sinned there was this intimate
uh relationship or meeting between the
father and the son
and there Jesus for the first time
intercedes after sin comes into this
world and notice this statement um
the angel is explaining this to Ellen
White about the meeting between the
father and the son he Jesus is in close
converse with his father.
>> And then she explains the angel, the
anxiety of the angel seemed to be
intense while Jesus was communing with
his father. Three times Jesus was shut
in by the glorious light about the
father. And the third time he came from
the father, we could see his person. His
countenance was free from all perplexity
and trouble. In other words, he entered
with perplexity and trouble with to
commune with the father. And when he
came out, there was no perplexity and
trouble. The question is why? Continues
saying, "His face, his countenance was
free from all perplexity and trouble and
shown with loveliness which words cannot
describe. He then made known to the
angelic choir that a way of escape had
been made for lost man, that he had been
pleading with his father."
He's interceding.
and had obtained permission
to give his own life as a ransom for the
race
>> to bear their sins and take the sentence
of death upon himself. Thus opening a
way whereby they might through the
merits of his blood find pardon for past
transgressions and by obedience be
brought back to the garden from which
they were driven. Then they could again
have access to the glorious immortal
fruit of the tree of life to which they
had now forfeited. All right. So Jesus
was intercessor
already.
>> Mhm.
>> In heaven as soon as Adam and Eve
sinned.
>> Mhm.
>> But he in the future he had to come and
he had to offer his blood
in order for his intercession to be
effective.
>> Exact.
>> I don't know if I'm explaining myself.
Yes.
>> And so and so uh this question, you
know, who was the intercessor before
Jesus began his high priestly ministry?
Well, he begins his prime min uh his
high priestly ministry now in heaven and
he has his real blood that really
forgives sin not on the basis of the
promise but on the basis of the
fulfillment.
>> Exactly. Now it's effective after the
cross is effective but he has always
been an intercessor even before sin. He
was an intercessor between God and the
angels and that has been a a function
that that Jesus had to take taken upon
himself the son in this case. Well, we
don't have time for the next question
but I think these two questions on the
sanctuary were very very good.
>> Amen.
>> I know that there is a series in the
sanctuary here that you have preached
pastor bore uh that people can find in
this in this channel. I think it's it's
called his ways in the century.
>> Right. Right. But you also did a series
here where you dealt more specifically
with the symbolism in the different
apartments and the curtains and and so
on.
>> I did that one in Spanish though.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, it was only in Spanish.
>> It was only in Spanish.
>> Well, we need to have you back to do it
in English.
>> Okay, that would be great
>> because there's never enough series on
the sanctuary. It'd be great to have you
do it in English as well.
>> Okay, we'll keep you posted regarding
that. Well, thank you so much for
joining us in our program today. Uh we
have come to the end of our program. We
enjoy your questions. It helps us grow
and understand better scriptures. So
thank you for sending your questions.
Thank you for being part of this. Share
this program with others so that they
can also be blessed and learn more from
the word of God. We will see you next
time. God bless you.
Heat.